[Music]
Wednesday roundtable how you live and
how you feel and Adam left go into
building Brian West for David angry yeah
how you guys do it
very excited ingress on the roundtable
I've gotten so many messages about
Dolphin tank
I've gotten so many messages from the
33% and the homies about pat pat that we
had to bring in plus you come up with
all the funny [ __ ] questions yes over
do I represent Pat Pat he's not actually
in the room right now as his agent Pat
Pat he's he's siloed off Brockton right
now he's at he's in his apartment in
Brockton right now he's a she's watching
she's a patty I've done it a really good
impression of him yes over the years
I've developed it close relationship I
entertain it
he has a lot of needs but he
communicates them well
- his ass yeah but you very talkative I
could tell you that he loves to get on
the phone and just sort of rant at me
for about 45 minutes and then I distill
that down into about 38 seconds and hand
it to you I love I love the Boston
accent dude and by the way what have you
been smashed in is Boston Boston that
was the worst Boston I know my accent
sound alike they all sound like the same
sitting in the back meaning that I have
been enjoying after every pod where we
look at each other and we go man we
learned another thing about Westbrook
was that you know whether it's like a
food thing or whether it's the accents
and what has it been like for you to
watch Westbrook do all the funny things
that you've written down what we haven't
gone back to the movie trailers in a
while which might have been my ultimate
favorite thing that I've seen you do
where it was like oh my the the scared
mom voice you always see in a movie
trailer
oh my god what's gonna happen yeah that
I thought was one of your best acting
performances I'm not an actor I don't
know have something do you have some
chops you think so you're right who's
the best athlete turned actor is it's
Dwayne the rock Johnson right well
you're Brown was it best me I don't know
he was definitely make those connections
around
- athlete acting is like Wilt
Chamberlain - like the current MBA
mm-hmm well I'm like I guess so like for
what it'll be no nobody had ever seen it
before and checking rules in Hollywood
back yeah totally different yeah I think
the rock probably would be the guy yeah
okay do you consider John Cena an
athlete well if you consider Wayne John
I mean he was a college football player
but I considered Wayne played more
athlete laughs let X than John Cena and
I also think John C is a bad actor
he's funny though he makes me laugh I
think I've been trained dreamin yeah yes
he was great but Dwayne Dwayne Johnson
holds the holds the athlete turned actor
belt for sure
speaking of which how bad like I think
Space Jam is gonna be tragic okay like
that's my take right now is I think
people are gonna go WOW LeBron really
[ __ ] up on space Jim that's a long
time it's hard to redo movies I would
never really do anything well one of the
best players that ever stepped on the
planet and now you're that guy
two words Ryan Coogler is he directing
it he's attached to it he's some sort of
producer he might be directing it but
I'm sorry like that guy makes hits he is
he did rocky or what's Rock Reed Creed
and black panther Fruitvale station like
he's incredible alright that's pretty
good that's like that's like saying you
know what I got a feeling this offense
gonna be making like do you know their
offensive coordinator is right from Kyle
Shanahan to cha McVeigh right you're
like okay yeah
damn Ryan Coogler alright so we're gonna
get to the cup we also put on social if
you could ask any questions what would
it be
umber is gonna moderate that but the one
news story that I feel like we have to
get to is this Kaepernick story where
the NFL seemingly unprompted offered him
excuse me demanded you either workout
Saturday at this time at this field in
Atlanta or you don't do it at all and I
want to say that my takeaway from all of
this because everybody has already
examined it you know I've seen so many
takes about it mine is I'm so happy that
we live in a time where we can get both
sides of the story because I believe
that there would have been a time where
this would have been a blurb in a
newspaper and then we would not have
known about how it was thrown on
Kaepernick and we would have looked at
each other and gone
well here's his opportunity and we this
must have been in the works it's been so
interesting that that takes the very
next morning have been Wow the NFL threw
this on Kaepernick and not let's see how
Kaepernick does it like we've gotten the
other side of the story so quickly and
for Kaepernick to say can't wait to see
all the head coaches and GM's that will
be there was beautiful because then they
get to come out and go oh there were no
head coaches or GM's maybe Kaepernick
was being sarcastic when he said that it
was it was beautiful it absolutely was
but I also think it's set it up to be
like it's it's an underhanded way of
going you're [ __ ] me right and I know
you're [ __ ] me it's Saturday cuz
you're gonna send like the social media
directors assistant to come down here
and represent the Titans it's a Saturday
I mean whatever coach is doing on a
Saturday not that preparing for a
football game to try to win a game on
the Sunday yeah so what maihama do what
a lot of the scouts are doing yeah
football that's right they're traveling
around the country going to college
football games why is it happening in
week 11 at the NFL season why isn't it
happening in mid-april when when teams
are looking about quarterbacks they're
looking at the draft they're saying like
three years ago by the way sure how
about saying if you're gonna do it in
2019 why not three months before the NFL
season before the trade deadline or
before the season or April like you're
saying where we haven't even gotten to
the draft yet right
my first thought is they did a few weeks
ago announced jay-z being a part of the
diversity coalition I do wonder if this
was like you should really do this I
don't know if they threw it together
last second on purpose as like you
always say to me don't always assume
malice right so then okay let's do that
here okay let's assume that the NFL is
not trying to [ __ ] over Colin Kaepernick
let's say that they literally had the
idea on Monday you know what let's
[ __ ] do it Saturday so the most
optimistic view is that you wait until
week 11 when teams are like really
really desperate for quarterbacks
they're like look we got a stretch run
before the playoffs we really need to be
that how you maximize his chance of
getting signed to a team what if that's
how far back Goodell is on his to-do
list
and was like you know what can we do it
Saturday we don't play on Saturday yeah
let's see if they could do things I'd to
rake my leaves I'd to get new contacts
smack in the face for Colin Kapernick
and that's like the giveth oh yeah but
if jay-z had something to do with it it
doesn't make any sense because it's not
helping column E it's hoping calling in
the way he's gonna be able to get in
front some teams if he wanted to do that
in this way but jay-z had anything to do
with it this is not the right way to do
it not on the Saturday not in week 11
not when caller just found out about it
the same way that we found out about it
this is this is a crazy way to do it oh
the absolute wrong way to do it it's
it's like one of those things where it
felt like a publicity grab but they
didn't realize it was gonna give them
the exact wrong publicity you know like
they wanted to go oh wow they're giving
him a chance but instead it's like even
in the chance they're giving it to it
looks pretty lot when and I'm gonna
equate this to another thing that's
rooted in race in the NFL it's when like
Terrell Austin goes on eight head
coaching interviews because all them
when hey guys let's get the Rooney rule
out of the way or hey let's get Eric B
enemy and they're like they're never
called and again or the way that we the
we just hire Adam GaSe without
interviewing any people of color okay
and so those two things feel very
similar to me we're like sure are um
doing something that seems to be good
for the cause yeah but at its core is it
no you're not doing this to save face
well first of all when did the NFL start
II start putting workouts together for
an individual player when did that
happen
well you say we have one guy we're gonna
put it workout together and listen I
think it's a good thing for Colin but at
the same time when did they start doing
one workout for one guy when did that
happen and in the middle of the season
so this is a prime time for the NFL to
be doing whatever the NFL does making
money advertising and different things
and they're doing a work into putting a
workout together how does that happen
I'm like simultaneously torn from
wanting Colin Kaepernick to put the
livestream on his website and we should
absolutely you to like make some money
on this he could make a million or two
on that at the same point I really hope
and I believe
leave Colin when he says I'm working out
five days a week last three heating up
and it's black and I like because the
thing is is he knows that if there was
ever a time where you know I'm an I
would take a week or two off that's when
the NFL is gonna come coming so I hope
that he is and I believe that he is and
I really think the best case scenario is
he goes out there and he [ __ ] kills
it and they put out videos and we're
going holy [ __ ] I think he does go out
there and kill it I think he goes out
there it looks better than dreamt Jeff
Driskel I hope he calls up Terrell Owens
I'd like to be like his wide receiver he
has to have nafeel capability yeah
they're like an all [ __ ] Pro like
Anquan Boldin's not that far out he was
really good he gets days yeah like
getting it Dez would love to be there
that's what I'm saying like really if
you want to do it let's get all the guys
that have been quietly back blackballed
yeah like let's put them all out there
and do like a super showcase I like that
and you know what if I'm a wide receiver
that's not that far out of the game like
I'm calling up cap and I'm going I will
[ __ ] be there tomorrow
you got all 32 teams like in if in a
weird way I'm hoping that Kaepernick's
people are working overtime and it sucks
that it's on them to like probably
organize all of this because you know
they're gonna get there the day of
there'd be like is there a speaker to
play some music like and they're gonna
be like oh no you got an I old iPhone
chord Oh Tom's job you don't have a
dongle oh do you think Matt Moore will
be there as a scout for the Chiefs from
Scout to kindergarten teacher to
starting on Sunday Night Football Matt
Moore
yeah but it's it's annoying that it
seems like they're [ __ ] him over I
hope he [ __ ] them over by putting on an
absolute show but the other question is
is like let's look around the NFL
Westbrook who like okay though every
team in the NFL the number one excuse
thing that can all make is yes is Colin
Kaepernick maybe better than Jeff
Driskel if a Detroit Lions yes but if we
had to play tomorrow Jeff Driskel knows
the offense and Kaepernick doesn't and
that's my thing it's not even about the
teams it's like he has no time to learn
anything to be of any value at all like
the only value get him Adam is like hey
we're gonna do a flea-flicker or a trick
play where you have one or
sponsibility but the learning
opportunities are small I don't agree
with that because I think that he's a
veteran quarterback that has been in a
few different systems while this time in
San Francisco the most important thing
is that in the NFL right now Colin Mary
watts in mahomes a little bit Wilson
obviously Lamar Jackson you've seen
athletic quarterbacks the best athletes
on the field playing the quarterback
position that's exactly what he was when
he was playing the best athlete in the
field playing the quarterback position
you put him on any team you say listen
here's a couple plays we got an out
route we got a comeback we got a you
know a dig and the rest you gonna make
it up and you're the second string third
string guy anyway
so we're not asking you to save the
season we just want you to hold the fort
down just for a little bit while our
quarterback is resting for two weeks can
you do that because listen where you
have the legs that's why that's why Josh
Allen was successful last year he wasn't
a great passer he had the ability to use
his legs Lamar Jackson last year did
didn't do anything great with this arm
he had the ability to use his legs now
of course when you bring a guy in like
that especially let's say you didn't
bring him in next week we get you have a
little package you say I got 10 plays I
want you to learn and we're gonna just
get to our be our best at these ten
that's it and he's old enough he's smart
enough he's been enough systems to
understand these are the Tim plays here
are the things I'm looking for I know
what cover to cover three cover five is
and we're just gonna play that to me
that's that's exactly what you would do
and if I'm in a situation where I'm
going into the playoffs and I don't know
who the backup quarterback is for
Seattle Seahawks right Matt or why
wouldn't you say you know what Russ goes
down with the ankle injury you know
Smith by the way okay Gina ain't heads
and tails a little bit different but
hails I think that you say hey why not
give him a chance bring him in the camp
he has to be better than your third guy
right well here's how I look for sure
the one that makes the most sense is
Baltimore because it's Greg Roman the
same one that he has in San Francisco we
have our g3 and that's why I go they
don't need him and also I think that's
what's so interesting about Kaepernick
is we always say what team could he put
them over the top and I would say let's
look at actually the people that are
looking more towards next year the
defining thing about Kaepernick
this whole situation was his biggest
mistake was the contract he signed that
was not guaranteed
after each year he signed a series of
one-year deals and that's why the Niners
were able even after he signed you know
I was like a hundred million dollar deal
but it was really a series of sixteen
million dollar deals it was over so I
actually have a top three list and kind
of teams that I think should go after
Kaepernick not to put him over the edge
this season but he might be the answer
in the future
give him the offseason give him the rest
of this year to learn obviously number
one is Chicago you're not going with
Travis key long-term but what did we
love about true Biscay that made this
bears often so darn special the ability
to run and if I have Cordero and Tariq
and can Kaepernick it could be
interesting maybe he doesn't play over
Tris key now give him the offseason full
quarterback controversy option number
one and get him on the bench for the
last month of the season right I'm
getting used to it
number two the team that was interested
in trading for Kaepernick and then
pulled the plug the Denver Broncos and
John Elway you liked all al Kaepernick
is tall you got an option offense with
Royce Freeman and Phillip Lindsay and
what they've now developing and
Courtland Sutton and guess what he's
gonna make that really bad left tackle
that Elway absolutely whiffed on a few
years ago it's gonna make him look a lot
better and know a fan-like beautiful but
my number one team and people are gonna
go you're crazy okay is the Pittsburgh
Steelers mmm cuz you don't like Mason
Rudolph at all he's not you god you're
like and call me crazy I'm not believing
that Big Ben's gonna have a good rehab I
just don't think that Big Ben's one of
those guys that's gonna be like JJ Watt
in the forest hacking wood and working
on his abs he's just never been that guy
I've never been that guy every time I go
this is my last big meal it's not it's
just the series that's how I think Ben
is and I look at Kaepernick and I go you
know who's a coach who could handle this
Mike Tomlin Mike Tomlin is the kind of
guy that can get that locker room
together and go all I care about is
winners with that defense with him James
Connor and juju me
it's not the guy let him sit there and
then hey you know what if big bends and
guess what you're like to pick a predict
like four million yeah yeah five million
he's not that much Kansas City I would
add in there because Andy is creative he
doesn't necessarily fit with my homes
does but again he doesn't have to fit as
I am Matt more like we just know he is a
good next year he'll be a backup next
year too and oh my baby's your guy for I
know we talked about backups yeah my
feeling in terms of this particular year
though like let's say the Pittsburgh
Steelers signed him and he becomes the
backup right and let's say they sneak in
to become the six seed which is totally
plausible right and absolutely they win
in the opening round now they're heading
to New England let's say for round two
who scares me more Mason Rudolph heading
into New England or Colin Kaepernick
leading that team who has the potential
to run for 150 yards and throw for 204
and three touchdowns that's terrifying
to me and just that thought suggests to
me that he should be on one of these
were his ability to run is a part that
no one we talk about it all the time
about Lamar Jackson you can't gain plan
for that if he can still run again we
don't know what the heck he looks like
this one so he's 32 I know what I looked
like when I was 32 I got beat up just a
bit so let's say he could still run he
can still throw the ball still athletic
which I'm sure he is he's had three
years off I mean that ability in itself
is just like okay timeout we don't know
what the heck unscaled look we talked I
was talking to Eric Mangini today and he
said you know the one thing that scares
the Patriots dharmaraj is his unscaled
looks when they hit when they have no
film on a look
just imagine bringing that guy in third
and four critical situation now he's
under center now you know what the heck
is gonna happen exactly he would be
tasting hill and now you're making me
think of okay if we gave Kaepernick to a
top offense of mine yeah Sean Payton has
found a guy like Taysom Hill or Shanahan
really really the real answer the best
team for Kaepernick to go to would be to
the Patriots I look I would love it I
would love it and and because if there's
one team that really needs another
weapon because of all your injuries we
don't know what we're gonna get one to
kill Harry comes back right is Phillip
Dorsett really a game changer like I
have a lot of questions about the
weapons on that team but also when the
Patriots sign a player is
they're knighted by the Queen we look at
them now and go Belichick has deemed
Josh Gordon a viable citizen of this
country and people went from calling him
a drug addict to he's a weapon
he's look at his statistics and the
Cleveland Browns 2014 Lyndon yes yeah
and so but the problem is is Kraft Brady
Belichick Magga Trump I'm not aware of
all of this discussion but like they're
the one team that if they signed him it
the world man it wouldn't explode but
there would be like a little sound if
you could put all of your political
thoughts aside and just think about the
football scenario of let's see let's say
the Patriots are down 2110 and yes and
Tom Brady is injured because he's 42
years old and Muhammad's a news behind
center with Kaepernick split out why I'm
just saying there's like Edelman who has
the chance to do a comeback in the third
and fourth quarter of a playoff game is
it Jared Stidham or would I trust Colin
Kaepernick to just bring us over the top
I gotta say like yeah I feel like it's a
no-brainer I can't believe people don't
feel this way
okay we'll be cool cuz Bruce Arians
develops quarterbacks I think that would
that would be a great idea yeah who the
heck Nobles was going on in the Chargers
after this year that's but my thing is I
would never want him to go to a
situation that's why I was like okay
Josh McDaniels of the Patriots would be
fun
Sean Payton already has his guy Kyle
Shanahan unfortunately there's no way
Kaepernick's going back to San Francisco
she's not a it's not possible right but
it would be a lot of fun and then the
other one that I love is Sean McVeigh
and LA would be kind of cool and kind of
stagnant honest I would love to make the
argument that cap predicts better than
golf because I'm already halfway there
and all I need is a nice glass of Pinot
Noir and I might I might take care of
recovers yeah that's I mean it's fun to
have the conversation from just a
football perspective would you pay the
money for the pay-per-view to see him
I'm pretty sure I would how many our
money is let's say it's 99 no fifty-nine
you would you a payin no I will
absolutely 10 friends over and you
charge them everybody's
friends of my apartment ever like that
sounds miserable Adam where do I sit
where do I put my coat no get the [ __ ]
word snack so I'll do what I do for
every UFC pay-per-view that like I
realize is actually that night and I
should catch the main event right
I go to Reddit and I find out where it
is and I I don't pay for those things
really I am a cord cutting don't be like
millennial don't be like that why my
content is free that's true
so it makes sense yeah well no I just I
would pay for it because I was raised on
the Internet where everything could be
found for free
and it's really hard to give that up
mm-hmm like every website is like
shuttering left and right oh man into a
plus excited to announce starting next
fall BR plus I'm just kidding but coming
next April left Co plus that's right for
$2.99
you can download an app that gets
exclusive webcams
when I wake up when I go to bed when I
take naps and the things that I really
think but I'm too afraid to say on the
left go show that's left go Plus coming
in April 2 99 would you pay for that no
I wouldn't okay now he's doing you a
livestream it - oh my god
for the left kites lights the levees
I love when people come up with little
nicknames for like segments and stuff
huh
so like I would well like we if if we
had people that loved dolphin tanks so
much they call themselves tanki's mm-hmm
well you know what how about Super Bowl
week we're handing out dolphin tank tank
tops to the fans that's pretty good
in Miami yeah did you really think of
that just now Wow off the top of your
head see that's pretty good just called
dolphin tanks dolphin tanks and tanks
hold on this is one of David's best
abilities like he has a fake podcast
here called the Loch Ness monsters we
spend all week coming up with one lock
and like for example you know you choose
like the when the Patriots were favored
by seventeen and a half
over the Redskins you had to bet like
$11,000 to win 1,000 when it came
through that's an extra thousand dollars
who say no to an extra thousand no boss
so they do this pod call the Loch Ness
monsters where their lock of the week is
the biggest favorite of the week and
they just take it money line and they
won like five weeks in a row and then
then we bet on the Saints instead of it
Falcons the whole time I was watching he
lost so they lost their whole but that
was no that was only six K it was six K
to win one case so we're still we're
still alive so the best thing about this
Westbrook is none of its real money
right but he was explaining this to
Warren sharp and Warren's reaction was
like oh wait you're not actually betting
real money on this tomorrow you don't
waste my time he was thinking through
the positive evie if he's like okay yeah
so I get seventeen and a half point
favorite yeah I'm not putting eleven
thousand dollars of my own money
Warren Sharpe play poker I mean he seems
to be a but you probably would be a
great poker player I don't know it would
be weird cuz he would just be counting
money and Hubie counting numbers in this
hole that's that's what poker players do
don't know think David's a really good
poker player but part of it's because
he's really good at like selling and
acting and I find Warren he would be
like like I feel like he like react to
his positive evey yes by the way I'm
gonna tell the story more with Warren
tomorrow an all-time betting night with
being friends with Warren Sharpe on
Monday oh sure I hit two big parlays
this week I hit a Thursday night
moneyline + o / parlay on the Raiders so
I got the underdog moneyline and over
and then I did it again on Monday night
with Seattle the underdog moneyline /
parlay and that is one of the craziest
overs I've ever hit my entire life if it
wasn't ten to seven and in in that there
was two defensive touchdowns like they
took the the touchdown from DK Metcalfe
like ripped out as he was crossing the
goal line which was seven points and I'm
texting with Warren and I witnessed
Warren become a superstitious fan he got
two pairs of shoes at halftime and he's
like I'm opening and taking my mind off
the fact that we're not gonna hit this
over and he put on one of the pairs of
shoes and they started to score and he's
like I'm keeping the shoes on and he's
sending me pictures of him
wearing these shoes being like it's the
[ __ ] shoes and in my head I'm going
even the man that I believe to be the
smartest analytical mind discussing
football right now and mediate a
scientist where who spends like 21 hours
a day is currently feeding into my
superstitions that because he put on a
pair of sneakers we're gonna hit this
[ __ ] over and it was so much fun
because that's that's why I like to talk
about betting because it's not just
marveling at Russell Wilson and
appreciating the game of football when
you got a little juice in the game you
start yelling dumb [ __ ] and like texting
your friends and like I'm texting with
my guy that we got the parlay on and the
guys going Warren don't take off the
shoes like that's that's football that's
how that's my favorite [ __ ] [ __ ] you
saw him aside it it was great I mean you
dude when you hit a parlay yeah it's
worth it absolutely pays a little bit of
my bar tab from Sunday check
speaking of Sunday you want to talk
about its how much your boy don't do
this right now no no your boy don't do
no it's not okay are you gonna expressed
it this is an interesting discussion
what here it is so so we're hanging out
and all of his absolutely all I'm
worried about what store you're gonna
tell what you talked about like
messaging yes okay fine yeah so we're
hanging out we having a great time and
all his friends are great you know
they're all Eagles fans from Philly
right so this morning I'm on my little
Facebook get look at my messages and his
boy Evan is like oh what's up was great
hanging out with you can't wait to see
you again
we'll do it again soon kissy face emoji
huh what the hell just happened right
after and went oh I was do this emoji
supposedly so far we don't know what it
was all about well all I know is he
messaged me and was like I accidentally
is he French cuz maybe he was doing the
level on what side of the face that's
not okay yes but no that wasn't cool
just let him know that it's not cool
yeah well you this almost happen to you
with your mother-in-law no no with our
babysitter oh yeah that's so much better
oh my god I thought it was your
mother-in-law
no no so our babysitter's name is a BA
BBY so I texted her the day before she
was coming over to babysit I said hey
Abby we still on for tomorrow and of
course that autocorrects - hey baby we
still on for tomorrow which I mean just
automatically changes the entire tone of
the tags uh unfortunately you know like
I didn't actually hit Send but I went
through all the mental calculations of
like oh my god what if I'd actually sent
it and then I'd put the phone in my
pocket didn't realize it that a half
hour later I had all these crazy - like
I went I saw my life flashing I still
get angry when I type what the f and it
comes up what the duck and I'm like I
have time this word so many type of fix
for that you put in here the autocorrect
no you put into your contacts a
character like a person named [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then that becomes just a
word that your phone now recognizes like
if I write lef K in my text it knows
that I'm talking about left go because
that's now a word that's like been
programmed into my phone so you create a
person named [ __ ] [ __ ] and now it now
knows that whoa both of those words
thing I like about the most is like if
somebody was looking at your phone right
you're like who is [ __ ] [ __ ] Craig's cuz
I use the word [ __ ] [ __ ] a whole
lot more than I use duck and duck if you
were to do a voice for mr. FF and what
would he sound like he's pad pads
roommate they went to they went to
college together I went to and they you
know so it's more a fork fork [ __ ] no
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you mmm I'll go [ __ ]
yourself yeah but I don't feel that
spelled F uck but that's like ifu h ck f
yeah no W K no that's fork work that's
like Guy Fawkes from V for Vendetta all
the same thing to me I do have a note my
guy Matt Roux huge Jets fan hit me up
and he said I need you to tell Brian
Westbrook that he's not alone I too do
not like peanut butter and chocolate
good man he come like the defining he's
a conversation of this podcast I thought
for the last few weeks he said now if
you give me premium chocolate and peanut
butter
I believe that tastes good but he agrees
in the Reese's Cup he is a bit of a
foodie and he goes I don't know what
that is in the middle but it's not
peanut butter which is an interesting
discussion I love
whatever is in the middle of that it's
peanut butter and powdered sugar I'll
mash together with it ah so that's not a
real peanut butter annulation yeah no
wonder it's a peanut butter ooh it's
like it's a substitute peanut butter
it's a mirepoix no good no good and this
guy met obviously the smart man
yeah he's intelligent he's probably a
Harbert I can tell now that was this guy
is smart I can tell ya he hates Reese's
Cups everybody doesn't hate him he
doesn't eat them oh and I got a text
from my friend Brad who's been in the
restaurant industry for I don't know
ever and he texted me about an hour ago
after catching up on the food take pod
with Robert Griffith I have one thing to
say about Westbrook he wouldn't know a
good meal if it sat on Holly's oh wow
that's harsh
Brad's the one that at that amazing
restaurant American cut huh he's the one
that hooks it up really so maybe we'll
do a dinner outing
that's was a connection and and Brad's
might make me bill bringing a few dishes
and we'll test your culinary because
David's a foodie too is he you're the
one do you take food advice from skinny
guys really do you know I take advice
from people that have gone I made a
quiche over the week I like to cook like
I do this man gets oh yeah and I make it
instead of a crust of like a pie crust
and make it with hash browns as the
crust now tell me you don't love like
eggs and bacon with some pepper and an
omelet and a quiche this is just a
different delivery system than an omelet
it just has like a crusty you know
potato we bottom that's my favorite tell
you something that you that you don't
you won't believe
I don't like armless either okay wait
what do you like eggs I don't like eggs
I don't like see it you don't like
scrambled eggs no do you like egg whites
I don't like anything I don't like this
credit I feel like the egg that you're
eating this is kind of graphic if you're
gonna say
don't steal Sims as long no not that and
I won't go that far but I feel like it's
a baby chicken that hasn't been what is
that food that really rich people eat
that is an undeveloped ära no no it's
like one of those like you peel apart
and you see like the baby chicken
Ortolan is that the thing they ate in
the show billions yes and actually in
succession can you describe that to
Westbrook and then while we describe it
if there's any way to only take
a close-up of Westbrook's face yeah it's
um and again I only know it from the
show billions and from the show
succession so I might be described but I
believe it is a small game game bird
like a Finch or something but it's like
tiny tiny bird and they overfill it with
some sort of like you know very rich
foods all into its stomach and then they
kill the bird by drowning it in Armagnac
so what some people are these and then
the way they serve it it's literally
just a plate with a dead bird on it I'm
not kidding like you know you know when
your food like looks like a turkey it
looks like a chicken this just looks
like a dead bird you hold it by the feet
you put the whole bird in your mouth up
to like the ankles how you eat the whole
thing and then you eat it bones and all
which apparently so softened from like a
lifetime of being force-fed all this
food this is like one of the the wealthy
is how is it described gamey no but
people say is like in your are you
supposed to eat it while wearing like a
tablecloth over yes it is typically you
put a tablecloth over your head which is
like are you guys making this up no I'm
not I'm not my screen additions are so I
googled this after the show aired
because I was like this can't be real
and it is you put the the tablecloth
over your head a it blocks out your
vision and your hearings that you're
just potato this live thing I'm sure the
smell is something but also it's like
this acknowledgment of the shame of what
we did to this animal in order to make
it as delicious as it is and they say
like they react on the shows at least
that it's like the most incredible taste
you'll ever have
I will never experience that taste em
hmm that but your face Westbrook but how
did they figure out that that's
something to yeah it's always by how was
that how did that happen it's like I'll
watch like a drug movie right like in it
it wasn't below it was one where they
that you're going through the jungle and
you're watching them make the cocaine
right and you're seeing like gasoline
and you're seeing like on fire and I'm
always like who [ __ ] thought of this
in the beginning yeah like it's the the
the normal joke is who's the first sick
[ __ ] that said I'm gonna get milk from
that cow you know I mean but yeah like
who looks at a bait burgers let's just
fill it up and stuff it and then eat it
up to his ankles I think that way about
like mushrooms and berries and things
that someone was like mmm I saw that
squirrel eat that berry I bet it's fine
for humans to eat and then we just
in their mouth very reasonable I read
that dumb fact where it said on a totem
pole the sign bear means teacher because
bears showed us how to hunt for fish and
eat berries that's the reason you watch
animals do it and then you go okay we
could probably do that yeah you've never
seen the animal feel another bird a baby
bird with stuff and then eat it Kodiak
bears deer yet confident rare is it is
Kodiak I thought it was Kodak bear but
that's just a bear Alexa be on cam a
really photogenic baby Kodak bear all
right let's uh why don't we do how do we
do this well do fan question rotated
with the cup okay so I'll be a bigger
banger as they call it the business man
is one thing so we'll go with a Twitter
question first yes by the way thank you
to the 33% for responding with some
really great questions I'm sorry we
can't get to all of them there were a
whole bunch of good responses but at
Irvine underscore Sanchez C NFL players
have a quote welcome to the NFL moment
what was Adam left goes welcome to be
our moment I think I don't know why this
came to my head we had a shoot where I
was supposed to go meet up with Usain
Bolt mm-hmm - and he was doing like a
press thing and we walked in there and
we had our own like dedicated area and I
looked over and there was a scrum of
reporters like lobbing questions at him
and I had spent my entire career in
scrums
and now I had this area to the side
where I like I got ten minutes with him
mmm
and I looked at the reporters and I saw
how much they [ __ ] hated me and I was
like wow I don't have that was like a
that was a unique thing and then it was
like I also was like you saying how are
you cuz when you were in the scrums
you probably looked over and saw some
veteran reporting you're like [ __ ] that
guy get 24 years I was like I could do
better than them you know I mean like oh
why because they go to a lot more people
than me
yeah and now you're the guy no in that
situation you're the guy well no now
I've gotten like spoiled too like I
don't like to be on radio row anymore
like in the beginning it was like why
won't this company put me on radio row
and then eventually reach a point where
you're like I don't want to be near that
madhouse can we find a way to not be
there how did they put me on radio row
now Radio Row is fun for a guy like you
but like I was talking to Warren about
it
your guys key is you need to have a
schedule because you're gonna get
grabbed by [ __ ] 90 to 60 pika right
and you're gonna be like [ __ ] he's like
what you told me you'd be on in 10
minutes we're gonna ask you the crazy
questions prop bets 92 things in Topeka
drive time all this smooth jazz don't
why they're at the Super Bowl all right
David I get to go first
what voice do you want to do I was just
watching rounders
so I'll do Teddy KGB did you like the
movie around herself seeing it loved it
okay I've watched it a hundred times
movie he knew you and you're scrolling
on Netflix yes all NFL team team names
just came to the life it bear a jet
raven etc which division would win a
battle royale got the gist of it say him
he's Manny it's like him his eye
simultaneously always wonder like what
the director thought when Malkovich came
in and did it like was he like this is a
little bit over the top but it's also
John so I actually heard Koppelman talk
about this exact thing that they had
like got John Malkovich to sign on to
this movie and like helped it make it a
go picture but they had no idea what he
was gonna do with the picture and like
literally the first shot that they the
first scene that they shot was the head
to the heads up match at the I think I
believe that was how do you do that in a
movie like that's why I think actors are
wild that they can like in a movie you
filled all the pent-up emotion of the
last hour and a half but they shot that
first
yeah that's curry and it was like I
can't remember the exact story but it
was something like they sat down it was
Matt Damon who's like you know looking
his Matt team is such a serious actor
looking at his cards and whatnot and
then he's he has some line that's like
yes I ended like just Damon lost at no
one
that had any idea he was gonna come in
so hot with that character and you're
watching I'm because we've all been on
set for stuff and like you watching me
like I wonder if this is gonna work and
write it above its new Malkovich new cuz
he's the greatest he is [ __ ]
unbelievable alright so the question was
the mascots come to life a bear is
actually a bear a lion is a lion this is
a throwback to many pods that we've done
what which division it would win a
battle royale so let me go from the AFC
and I'm gonna do it quickly a patriot a
buffalo a dolphin and a jet interesting
combination I know the answer
oh alright well I'm gonna look at the
divisions no no no how many you give me
yours NFC North mmm cuz they have a bear
which is a tough-ass Hannum yep a lion
yep which is Viking which is might dud
as a man number one in the human based
mascot ranking that's right like if a
Vikings facing a patriot or a Buccaneer
that's right the Viking is the most
savage of all okay and they have a
packer and I'm not a hug person sure
with that I don't know it's a cheese
head maybe or someone that's packing
clothes or so they be organized and
vicious yes I'll and they have food to
the symmetry of like a Viking riding in
on a bear and a packer riding in on a
lion that's just the coolest look is
like a man on a limb and on an animal
that's like a good formation that they
true-true like the East is funny because
you're like okay the eagles flying on
top and there's like a giant walking
down and I cowboy all right no
Washington on the left and you're like I
don't know that's a good image but
they're not winning I would take the
Aniston north over them are you anywhere
yeah I think it's it's a no-brainer I
think if you have a Titan on your team
everything else is moot hmm I think a
Titan it isn't that a god or a demigod
like a giant or a patriot driving a jet
you know though it's a Titan it's a
horse in the Colts it's a Jaguar and
it's that's I honestly think the Jaguar
the Colt in the Texan could kind of like
hang out on the sidelines and just let
the Titan destroy all what I thought
that's the way I feel but I could be
wrong AFC West you have a Raider which
obviously is really the question mark in
that when I was just looking at it is
is a charger like the god of lightning
or is it a single bolt is there a
rapport is it how you recharge your
phone in case you're in the middle of
rattling let's check somebody great
question is literally a charger I really
think it might be the AFC North because
just no one's gonna step on a brown no I
think NFC South a saint
who's gonna harm a saint in the fight
well it depends a lot of people I would
if I needed to Panther but I do I do
think you're right I wonder if the Titan
is is it the secret weapon is that the
strongest mascot in all of sports
a wizard might have the ability to take
down a Titan I also I don't know what
blue is like a st. Louis blue just like
maybe like if you envelop someone in a
color it is a a you're done you're
awesome yeah that's good
all right fan question number two mister
anga this is from at anthony 3 davis it
is not the NBA all-star unfortunately
did westbrook have a back-up plan if
football didn't work out hmm well I
actually did because I went to Villanova
I didn't think that I didn't have a clue
that football was gonna actually work
out I was thinking find your way through
school get yourself a great degree at
Villanova University in in work you know
I'm saying like get like a real job like
you know I have a business degree I own
a few businesses and so that was my game
plan go find a way to learn a bunch it
would have been if you had to go right
out of college stockbroker
no okay no no no no it's more like real
estate real estate type of stuff yeah
you know managing some businesses on the
computers at the time which was cool but
now it's kind of crazy because I don't
know anything about what the hell is
going on I can't even imagine
ya know you had that whole like NFL
career that me a couple years here you
weren't interested in taking your
amazing instable a resume and try to
parlay that into like a college football
coaching job or anything like that I you
know I thought about coaching but then
so when you go into the NFL and
obviously this is a different type of
question when we go into the NFL the
coaches are spending 12 14 16 hours a
day yeah
in the
and that just sounds you because as a
player you're like man we're racing so
much time in between meetings coaches
having meetings that we don't even need
and just savage you from the coaching
experience and kind of the same way in
in college because you have coaches and
college that are like we don't want you
to go out partying so we're gonna have
another meeting and we don't want you to
do this so we'll have a practice and
we're like yeah come on coach
how many projects do you need I feel
like good players telling everyone to
become coaches
that's why Peyton Manning is just like
chilling out doing it's hard little it's
hard for good players to be coaches
because they're good for like the guys
like sits at the back of the line and
doesn't get read right he's like I see
how this coach at improving Brooke
well good players mike singletary I'll
use it as her great acting coach was
like he wasn't great he wasn't ready to
be a coach yet because are you telling a
Singletary story yeah I love Mike
Singletary as a man he just wasn't ready
to be a head coach but when you're when
you're a star all Hall of Fame type of
player you had instincts that other
people can't have right and so I can't
tell you how to be instinctual as a
linebacker or as a running back there
are certain things I feel that I just
see it and I feel it before you can even
see it
yeah and I'm able to make the play
before you even your senses aren't there
and so for me to tell you how to do
something that I just did naturally is
impossible that's why you said back up
guys so Gary I saw somebody else doing
this what you saw is that this exact
thing when Jason Kidd became a head
coach in the NBA I was like Jason Kidd's
gonna talk to every point guard and be
like just do what I did just be perfect
you just like hit the gap yeah hit the
gap and see the floor the way no one in
the history the game has ever seen it
why is a good coach it's kind of I guess
it goes me wasn't a start again you know
who's the best right now
old Stevie Kerr yes and he just sat
there and went oh that's an interesting
way to talk to Michael oh that's an
interesting way to talk to Tim Duncan
oh that's an interesting way to talk to
every other please play with Charles
Barkley
mm-hm and you get to observe more that's
why I like the second and third kid as
always the one that's like thinking the
most you know I mean like the first kid
you like I'm gonna make you a peanut
butter and jelly you say was the second
kids like on the counter making it
themselves
that's right with all the kids I have
all right Westbrook reach in there in
burr pick a voice for him oh actually
this is one of the
that we got we want Brian Westbrook to
do his Stewie from Family Guy voices
from at Conner Abbott don't like I
watched Family Guy sounds like it's it's
hello ha
I believe it's based on the voice of
regular Harrison hello mr. grades that
was the first clip on Stewie's one-line
the first clip that you have saved in
your damn computer what's the greatest
random video game of all time did what
don't you surfer guy they're all the
same people and make it a Spanish little
wine in here TC don't choose Mario Kart
or matter or go deny or any other gangs
that we agree are Hall of Famers alright
so say it again with your normal voice
you do that it's like we do it the funny
voice regroup and you're like okay
because he does these pauses and I was
like I can't laugh what's the greatest
random video game of all time don't
choose Mario Kart or Madden or Goldeneye
or any other games that are that we all
agree are Hall of Famers
agreed so like Mario karts in their
golden eyes in there oh I know
okay what's one of yours The Legend of
Zelda first of all my mother's name is
Zelda so just imagine what I'm she got
an epic quest she wouldn't have a quest
oh my brother protect yours Elda okay
this is before you didn't have a
Nintendo did you I never finished the
game so I never like when they're like
they're like told spoil the reveal I'm
like I'm never gonna get there but I got
these wrong well my mother's name is
Elle is Zelda it was a great adventure
you never you there's no way you
finished that game I would bet all of my
money's hey yeah I don't not probably
did know you like this game's boring
yeah yeah I'm out I'm out on this let's
play Tecna boat yeah that's what they
look like
do you have one I know you were
originally this question I have a few
yeah I have a few I mean I was a
1993 Nintendo guy say so for me like
that's what video games are like about
my wheelhouse rad racer was my game I'm
looking it was a it was a car driving
game and it was just I was obsessed with
it it was just so obsessed in this game
being like a seven or eight year old kid
and just like someone's super fast they
had these really awesome kind of like
Miami Beach and then like a California
looking one and then one in like the
Arizona desert I just like they looked
cool I'd never played a game anymore it
felt like something you only get in an
arcade and I know that like the the
under-23 crowd is listening to this
being like really a car driving game
blew your mind I'm telling you you have
to imagine a world where that didn't
exist and then it showed up in your
living room it was like the first time
you played duck hunt yes and you're like
I'm hitting a button and something is
[ __ ] happening on my television at my
house at my house at my [ __ ] house
cuz arcades were happening in the 80s
and 90s and stuff but like I now have a
plastic gun in my house and I can stand
ten feet away from my TV that was mine
below I never actually stood I always
went right that's cheating I was a
cheater so I did I I loved
duck on all that stuff the two that came
to my mind right away were Battletoads
if you remember Battletoads it was like
they were like they were like the x-men
I don't even know they were a little bit
like Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles but
like a little bit more correct I loved
all the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
games and the other one was roller games
roller games was this like roller
skating fighting game I had a roller
skating game that I was obsessed with
too extreme on place I also liked
monsters in my pocket there's another
game the weirdest thing I think about
growing up in that era was popular
didn't really exist so it's whatever
game you're [ __ ] ant got you from
toys-r-us believe that's the game you
played for six months and in your little
child brain you thought everybody is
playing Battletoads so I can go to any
room and go [ __ ] Battletoads and
everybody knows that but they didn't
this is the most validating thing you've
ever said this like changed my because I
spent ages 12 through 15 getting
incredible at battle arena toshinden and
was like I can't wait to dominate my
friends in this and then all of them
played Mortal Kombat
Tekin and like has ever even heard of
freaking battle arena toshin and I just
wasted so many hours of my life getting
incredible at this game that would have
no social capital to me oh sorry about
that bro but that's in but actually it
sounded sincere yeah I'm concerned I
wonder you know like we have these
amazing moments when we were younger and
now it's like even when I go onto
Netflix it goes
this video is trending and some people
are gonna go well if people are watching
this I would like to have that
discussion right especially with the way
we consume media like people come up to
me they'd be like hey man like I wasn't
able to listen to the podcast I'm like
dude how do you have any time to do that
ever but we we want to be listening to
things other people are listed we want
to be in the in-crowd FOMO all that [ __ ]
but I love the fact that like I played
games that people have never liked I
loved kick ol cubicle
holy [ __ ] it was bootleg Kirby his dude
would suck in and like spit out like
things and got into a fight with my mom
over it was great really so the only
game that you're gonna say was what
again I'm getting to sell dope Legend of
Zelda was an awesome game first of all
for sure yeah I'd have another one like
I liked NFL Blitz
I loved Mike Tyson's punch-out was one
of my favorite that's all that's a
hall-of-famer yeah technical obviously
hall-of-famer you were in a big video we
had three damn games that was all we had
you're a little bit older I didn't come
from your air isn't too busy something
here mom fan question yes this is from
hat not Matthew Evans I wonder if it's
actually Matthew have it's not Matthew
that's according to his Twitter handle
in the ultimate Ohio Bowl could a team
comprised of Ohio State's skill players
and the Browns lineman offensive end
offensive beat the Cincinnati Bengals so
like all they're special oh they're
current players now I think I think
we're all time I'd say right now we're
back is it's they're saying could if you
take the Browns lines because when you
talk about college versus the pros the
number one thing that would be
dominating the trip right exactly right
but you take that away now since their
corners it's their wide receivers it's
their quarterback it's their running
backs like could that team with the
Browns front seven and the answer is
could yes if you had to give me a
percentage
I'd say 39 percent
which is really high would you risk
$12,000 to win 1,000 no no way that is
interesting though I love when it one
team is so bad in the NFL and one team
is so good in college it always gets
that it would be the hard part for the
Ohio State players though because
they're fast they're just as fast are
just as strong maybe they don't know the
NFL lingo and things like that but let's
like we played when a college field
obviously wider has things like that
I've always believed that we don't we
never factor in the human element of it
of you have you're now putting a
professional athlete on the field with a
college player and that dude is gonna
did you put every morsel of his body
pride destroying that kid yes the kids
are doing it just to like like that you
need a special but they're doing it to
get into the NFL that was their gateway
into the NFL you take that question you
go whoever loses dies so that motivation
is the same because money isn't gonna
motivate you as much
yeah murder is pretty good yeah that's
what I use with my kids all right what
voice am i doing
yeah but I don't have money you have
them all the good ideas can we get a
little Elmer Fudd can you do our phone
for me I'm hunting wabbits okay I always
want to do I'll say I'll say I'll say
that's a that's the chicken foghorn
leghorn yeah which I think sometimes his
deliveries a little Steven a okay
little good take let's get data nah it's
a little actually that's more that's
where Shannon Sharpe what I think about
it Shannon's more Foghorn Leghorn
I think foghorn leghorn was supposed to
be sort of like a southern lawyer he's
like now your honor what I believe is
you know I just keep repeating what's
the greatest I don't know I what's the
greatest prank you've ever pulled or had
pulled on you obviously Mike Tyson
talkin yeah that was Mike Tyson that's
fine well you tell what they were asked
earlier abot the west go that's a
westerly wabbit can you do it as Mike
Tyson would that change at all with
what's the guize prank you've all pulled
oh I have pulled on you that's not bad
well pretty good I like that yeah I kind
of like Mike you know I'm a handful face
praiseful face girls mousse all right
what's the greatest prank you've ever
pulled or I'd pulled on you really we're
both gonna look at Westbrook and go tell
me a great time in a locker room
yeah locks in Frank's are always the
best and and you know what if it's not
on you but it was on a teammate and it's
one you'll never forget that's good to
that even if it's a story that you've
heard but you have to put yourself in it
and just make it a first-person
practicing writing fiction this is Frank
day they used to do all to all the
rookies and so we had the field right
and it's surrounded by you know a little
shrub trees tackle
ya got that there it is
but they had trees and so we'll be
practicing whatever you know all the old
guys would do this all too young guys
like man they got to the guys in the
trees are filming practicing and taping
it with the video cameras you see him so
everyone's looking like like I don't I
don't see [ __ ] like what are you talking
about he said no he's right there so now
all the old guys are like no he's right
there so now you're feeling like you're
you're crazy which was a silly little
prank but during the middle of camp
that's it's absolutely hilarious but
then you have guys [ __ ] usually the
pranks with hey look we've all seen
these similar pranks but they they they
take all the tape from like the training
room yeah go out to the rookies cars in
wrap them in tape which which is which
is not bad if it's sunny and 75 now if
it's raining yeah and then it dries mmm
that's when you can't get the damn tape
off your windshield mm-hmm and that's
not fun I know that's when the brake
goes too far so we we now we have to
fight my question is this we always know
that happens to rookies we always know
the victim who is the quadrant of
players on the team that executes the
prank right it's it's probably not the
quarterback and yeah it's not the
high-priced wide receiver deal I'm like
what is the position group that
typically pulls off the prey like this
are they like a second earth are they a
starter yes
it's usually started and second-string
guys are usually trying to make their
way unless you're like a name a second
stream got it and gets a bunch of
playing isn't a guy that's caught in a
contract or is he at the end of his
rookie deal he's got in the contract
young guys we got to get a contract
first just to be solidified on the team
because if this goes bad you want to
make sure that you still got an
opportunity play so yes usually the
older guys deal I'm an offensive line
but they always are thinking of crazy
stuff to do usually let the kickers
kickers have a more time there's a whole
drink have more time backup quarterbacks
do nothing any day every day they do ask
Lloyd ever a prankster coy was hilarious
do a bunch of pranks but he was he just
did funny stuff came out in one day and
all like all white suit just like not a
jumpsuit but like tights all like might
choose Mike Tiny's just look right a
little hat it was it was hilarious
he had to be there so all these perks
you have to actually buy yeah I get it
well he gives a lot of do you have
pranks that we're involving you that
were great I pulled a bunch when I was
working at major league baseball like on
yeah let's hear one there was one that
we pulled it was like a there was a
bunch of likes kind of like young
reporters that were we had them we're
gonna do like a really fast you know
this is on YouTube actually you can go
to see it was with Jay Bruce where you'd
have a chance to run up to Jay Bruce ask
him a question then run off right it was
like we were making this video of like
all these like young reporters that were
like applying to this job yes so like
they went you know what's your favorite
movie don't know what's your favorite
at-bat didn't you know just running
running running and like the fourth or
fifth one we yanked out the leg of the
table to make it look like he had
crashed into the table and his Silver
Slugger Award was sitting on the table
and it crashed the floor and Jay Bruce
is looking him like dude what that
what'd you do to my tin Jay Bruce was
great actually and like he was in on it
oh yeah he was he was he was the missile
we were making yeah the prank was on
this young guy and then he revealed the
press this is the problem with telling
pranks if you're not there it's never as
fun but I'm saying you can you can
witness this I want you I got I got what
I just remember one okay I got a good
this is good this is funny too so you
better stop hype right around
Thanksgiving time and your
the lab listen to me stop Thanksgiving
time to be preparing you would always
tell get your face straight okay you
would always tell the rookies like
listen we have a so so Andy Reid would
come into the team meeting and say
listen wewe are sponsored by whatever
grocery store Pathmark giant whatever
grocery store you have and we all the
rookies go over to the the grocery store
and get turkeys for the vets so they can
bring it back to the families and so now
all the vets go to the rookie is like
listen have you heard this one before no
they do it a lot of teams I want three
turkeys I want four turkeys and so now
you have a list of guys deuce once three
Dorsey Levens was too prime mister wants
four so I'm like I'm gonna have that
shopping cart full of turkeys so we all
the rookies go to the grocery store one
by one so they can't see each other and
they go to a store put all the the the
turkeys in and just try to walk out
right but the grocery stores they have
no clue what the hell is gonna they're
not in on the prank at all so now it's
like you're actually stealing four or
five six all the supermarket knows yes
so never bid obviously they're video
taking the whole time so now security
guards run out the other thing like that
they're acting like they're you're going
to jail now you so now you're trying to
explain nobody so for deuce and this is
for Dorothea and again you had to kind
of be there but it was fun no that's fun
it is not funny joke and someone goes
that was well explained it's what is
this fun yeah you know what the greatest
prank I've ever been involved in what
you're gonna see in three weeks on ditch
the playbook that's right final finale
of the season Travis Kelce prank yeah
hilarious prank hilarious do I have to
be there
see that's not it's not it's not okay I
come prepared if you have a video that's
not fair it's almost like pranks in the
show it's a great prank I was so proud
of the way we executed it and planned it
you have a prank now that was know do
you have another one that she explained
to us cuz I feel like laughing exactly
it's pretty hard to think of one that's
funny okay I got one good so one time my
are you pranking us that you don't have
a story right absolutely false whatever
these bodies
this is not a true story before I would
always get home before my parents okay
and so I would come home from school and
one time I took saran wrap and I lifted
up the toilet seat and I put it over the
toilet that's a classic um I can't move
yeah my mom sat down and I just heard
and then she went what off you didn't
have to be there yeah on herself yeah
shout out to Sharon good job mom
drip okay that was my Meegan for that
joke first of all your mom's gonna kill
you when she sees this he's gonna be
like yeah would you know she's gonna
raise you better than she's gonna text
me and she's gonna go listen the pod
thanks for telling that story yeah all
my friends love it no she call me drip
drip now
drip drip Sharon walks into mahjongg on
a Monday night
her friend Wendy goes your drip drip my
life will be made
George I can retire for this channel
drip drip all right so fat questions
okay @k McLovin 59 what is your favorite
type or flavor of cake or flavor of ice
cream mmm
first David is very particular I am
rules I do have some rules I'm a big fan
of just the the regular chocolate cake
with the vanilla icing so you get a
little bit of the both but I like the
moist chocolate cake is you know that
I'm just let's let's not [ __ ] around
with like the perfect cake you know and
then when it comes to ice cream I just I
love mint chocolate chip which is what
made me so sad the other day when you
hated mint and chocolate but if we're
going like really specific it's the Ben
and Jerry's flavor of milk and cookies
it's like a it's like their own sort of
like nut milk and cookies it's called
milk and cookies so the real question
that comes up what is the cake that you
hate and what is the ice cream that you
hate because when ingre doesn't like
something it has the full vigor and you
will rain down vengeance upon you want
to hear one of the most overreact to the
planet tiramisu
what are you doing why are you trying to
strangle me with chocolate powder we
have one of the most epic scenes from
the office of when Michael Scott's
trying to eat a bite of cake and then
try to talk on the phone it's a you
starts cooked
it's like a murder weapon I swear to god
I don't know what you mrs. exist okay it
along those lines in her and I ordered
tiramisu you would be like are you
[ __ ] kidding have you like enjoy it
dude I don't know why there's so many
good options overrated Oh exist and then
along the lines of them with a flavor
palate of tiramisu
I mean espresso ice cream why do you
exist oh my god I come on ice cream is
okay espresso io like Turkish coffee ice
cream what it's like really just
genuinely taste like a bitter cup of
coffee this is your dessert this is your
like delightful end to the meal of empty
calories like that's what you want to
leave the meal on that's how I feel
about Reese's just the Zac way Reese's
Reese's but I was thinking about hey did
you feel that way about olives yeah I
find olives disgusting but that just
might be like a me thing I'm also one of
those people that can I do evolve
they're delicious
my whole family is what assessment looks
palette what if Wes works palette is
just bizarro Ingmar Oh what if you guys
are actually connected and it's just you
have your the I do feel like a
connection with you so between between
the two Komatsu 100% of the foods on
planet Earth
January 19 is that like it's a Westbrook
so odd Inger has so but you know this is
what's funny is sewing bird does a
pretty good impersonation of me he has
two things would you like to see it yes
okay however you'd like to to do it yeah
this is my this is my two-pronged
impersonation of Lefko can you say
something that makes me happy just say
just say something that would like that
would make me happy just give me some
good news
delivery some go today is payday that's
awesome yeah yeah and then and tell me
something that would like kind of
discipline give him like news like news
just broke that's gonna disappoint you
yeah like someone got injured maybe
you're never gonna believe this Tom
Brady just got hurt
damn
no I missed it I [ __ ] it up damn damn
yeah that's that's my left go it's it's
that's awesome and damn good and I get
so self-conscious cuz some wannabe like
empanadas are here like that's awesome
[ __ ] but Westbrooks
is totally he would totally go
interesting interesting I did not say
anything that's it like he wanted to
know your birthday he's not gonna give
you his back you're gonna be like oh
you're an Aquarius so clearly no just
well here's the bad part I don't know
anything about the whole sign thing I
know is that if you're a Virgo like me
that we should be similar that's all
right I really thought he was like
there's a 1 in 365 days in Dolly Parton
and Xavier McDaniel January what 19th
queer and you're what Westbrook
September 2nd 1979 and junior say oh ok
I'm May 8th yeah yeah that doesn't mean
Floyd Mayweather just made that up I
don't know his birthday uh York up in
birth and let's do I'm gonna do my other
impression why don't you why did you
pick Floyd not all the people that you
could have picked words weren't coming
my mind fastball it's blowing oh what's
your other impersonation about Kendal
Roy from the show succession ok have you
ever seen success no I have it all right
my favorite character in like TV history
before you to do it have you heard the
theme song of succession I played this
for woody and she had not heard it it's
so good it's the best hold on
[Music]
it's just so sinister like sets you up
for like but also I intrigue looks like
this is the listens to me to the Ethan
ass oh my god alright anyway you need to
watch this show
it's [ __ ] the best show how did you
find that so quickly your own your cap
you have that say yes internet
millennial read I go okay this is if you
don't know the show succession this
won't be funny to you but if you if you
do do you'll know that was a very
accurate impression dad dad hey you wake
up and a genie tells you that you now
have one superpower dad which which one
would bum you up the most yeah I love
that
no I do two impressions I do left go and
Kendal Roy and I think they're both
solid they're really good alright so
this is the regroup of the question you
wake up and a genie tells you that you
now have one superpower which superpower
would bum you out the most hmm yeah cuz
most people go it's between flying and
invisible right right everyone knows the
superpower they want which one you find
out you buy out damn come on I started
thinking about this and I was like maybe
it's like the stretch okay
like I just feel like people would be
like can you get that can off the top
shelf at last a girl yeah but then I get
for other things to be dope I think if
you could be invisible it would be so
good but it also suck because you can
you get credit you'll never get credit
for the things that you could do because
no one can see you right there's also
like a creepiness thing that I don't
want to deal with as the invisible
solutely like I don't want to be with
like were you in my room and it's like
no I wasn't invisible at that time all
you do is see women like this covering
up is the thing when you talk about
superpowers and someone says
invisibility someone's always like
alright creep right right cuz all they
think is nasty things when you think of
you know that's the worst what was there
like one in like the Marvel's that like
people were making fun of a lot there's
like not a good oh I'm sure there I'm
not as well-versed in like the superhero
versus as I could be but the answer that
i came
I wrote these questions let me know my
answer is time travel because I would be
so terrified of the like the splitting
the time continuum and like you know I
go back in time and it messes something
up and then I don't meet my wife and
then my daughter's never born like all
that stuff would freak me out and I'd
never end up using my superpower whereas
if I could fly I would just go up might
fly I could use it however I wanted to I
would not want to be I would not want to
be wouldn't you be terrified to go back
in time and change no I wouldn't I would
love it because I have the fate of the
world in my hand
Oh question for Westbrook you can go
back in time where are you going what
are you gonna do go yeah if I could go
back in time where would I go it's just
in my life with just ever I would okay I
would go to a time and place this is
just a sports one I would go back to the
beginning of Michael Jordan's career
just to see that one more time I would
like I would love to say that one more
time I wouldn't do his high school gym
yes to be a spectator get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah you should have gone back
if you wanted to play football and go to
lighting for the first football field
ever and be like I'm about to be the Jim
Thorpe and rewrite all the record books
so it's Brian westbrook's the greatest
athlete of all time but you wouldn't
exact answer was killing Hitler so
clearly you don't care about Jews how I
would use time travel and the only way
that I would use it is at the poker
table where I could just go back like 10
seconds and reverse bad decisions that
I've made or like bad beats and things
like that and I would just be able to
fold or so I could just accrue millions
of dollars but I'd literally only go
back ten seconds I'd still be sitting in
the same chair that I was so I wouldn't
be impacting future events or changing
to go back to college and just do it
over one more time just if the world
worked out the exact same let's go back
one more time and redo Villanova I
Wharton I will say that like there was a
time where going back in time sounded
great but now with like technology and
my reliance on it going back in time and
being in a place where someone's gonna
be like you got you got a nickel for the
payphone I'd be like get me the [ __ ] out
of here Connecticut Yankee in King
Arthur's Court and you're just like hey
they wouldn't be cool to go back to our
three end times you go back and there's
like no plumbing and like never washes
their hands before could they remember
there was like some movie where
think it was Martin Lawrence that went
back in time and he was like a knight
and there's a part where like some girl
like puts on a discman headphones like
she just naturally knows to put them on
her ear and hits play and it's like
Coolio just like oh these things like I
just think that's such a funny scene
that they're like how are we gonna show
what Martin Lawrence is like in time
right disk I don't know what my worst
like I don't know what the worst traits
are for a superpower I would rather be
able to like teleport than time-travel
okay yeah I'd rather be like hey I'm
gonna go to Cairo really quick hey
here's some sand the only way that that
would be awesome to me is if everyone
liked you could ask someone to like be
touching your shoulder and they could
come with you so like I could take my
dad I could take my wife out to dinner
in Paris tonight you know and then just
like snap our fingers and we're right
back yeah they like Savin Yul and it's
like only her arm messed up in travel Oh
God
sick sick minds you guys have very much
so no I wanted to take my daughter my
wife and daughter out to a nice dinner
with their arm
what another fan question yes at Bon
Temps underscore roller writes wtfast
rose did you hear about that I did hear
about that when I feel like you're
Eagles team when you hear another team
cheating it brings up weird thoughts on
you it does because you so here's the
thing at your team in the super cast
Rose now spy game there were three
turnovers and you just have to wonder
naturally did they get those turnovers
because they knew the play mm-hmm they
knew the signals they knew the signs or
just we just played shitty and they just
got the football that has to be the
question every time I will say that the
way that I feel is interesting I thought
about that before the way that I feel
about Belichick and all the gates is the
same way that I feel about Calipari and
recruiting they've been so successful
for so long and like I know Bella
checks been caught but like a lot of
Bella checks things were like kinda like
a lot of teams were doing I'm like I
don't think he was the only one the line
between cheating and gamesmanship yes
yeah at the same time because are Eagles
I feel like they cheated like a
[ __ ] well there's a hard line
between stealing signals stealing some
is that what did you guys hear that the
Patriots were doing like what did you
hear was you were taking the signals
from the sidelines as a signal I'm into
the quarterback from previous games and
now they have a better opportunity to
figure out what defenses can stop those
specific plays which again it's hard to
do in 25 30 seconds like even the Astros
thing they were like they were able to
look at the sign and then someone in the
dugout would go
which meant changeup is coming right but
it was coming like a millisecond and
then the batter still had to hit the
change well it's a different world for
baseball it's much easier because one of
the things at baseball the reason why
you want to pick up the ball so early
out of the pitchers hands so you can
understand what type of ball you get as
a fastball oh this is a curveball so
you're saying this is coming slower this
is coming faster and you anticipate it
that's that's why if you know a
curveball is coming it's much much
easier if your analysis that's that's
why it's it's such a cheating moment
fastball fastball I'm a great fastball
hitter I'm swinging the damn bet do you
what how do you think Astros fans feel
about their championship they don't care
the Patriots fans don't care I gates
could ask a Patriots fan right we feel
weird as we know sports fans will do all
sorts of mental gymnastics to make it
seem like this was you know they've
totally railroaded here and like the
whole two-and-a-half years that people
were talking about deflategate I was
watching like MIT professors on YouTube
talk about the ideal-gas law and how
actually it couldn't have been nearly as
bad as it you know people thought it was
etc etc when it comes to gamesmanship
and you know like I'm obsessed we've
talked about poker a little bit on this
podcast I'm obsessed with the Phil Ivey
sod get saga where a casino accused him
of cheating but in fact he was edged
sorting and he was only edged sorting
because the casino agreed to use a
specific brand of card that's on the
casino to look into whether or not these
the story was desire to have a story is
that Phil realized they were using a
certain deck that had a pattern on the
back that he could that he could ask the
casino to use a certain kind of Krait
because when you're when you're going to
casino and you're sitting down with like
three million dollars you get to ask for
certain things so he wanted a certain
dealer and he was like I want that deck
of cards and they agreed to it and there
was a design on the back where he could
look l if there was a half a diamond
that had a better chance of being a face
card he's playing blackjack and he took
them fur I think it was twenty-two
million dollars at a variety of
different casinos it was baccarat which
makes it even cooler for some reason
Atlantic City right he did it in in
Vegas in London there were a couple of
casinos in London but I think it was all
casinos owned by the MGM yeah and they
kind of found out and they refused to
pay him and as ingmar saying it you
could have said no to this deal right so
so anyway I bring that up only because
good story I find someone like Phil Ivey
and who Phil Ivey was asking for
everything every step of the way the
casino had every ability to do their own
game protection and figure out a way to
just say we will not allow this to
happen so if you can do something that
that is right up to the line and I
actually think that that's like almost
part of competitiveness and I think
Patriots fans have been able to write
everything off that Belichick has gotten
caught for as like he was trying to do
everything possible that was legal right
and that like we should be applauding
him for doing that for going the extra
mile for his team because there are some
things that you could do that are shady
but not necessarily illegal well if they
should be banned from the game then just
make them illegal right and my two
things are this one I hate that
deflategate has brought up for Belichick
it was not a Belichick thing Brady is
the only person that could be accused of
anything now people will say it's like
the the you know I will never forget
when Bella cheque stood up at the podium
and said don't ask me anything talk to
Tom and I went that was the beginning of
their riff yeah because I I don't put
any of the flag gate on Belichick any I
still think that there was some
deflating I think the text message in
destroyed phone's court but that's how
some I want to get into now with the
Eagle spy gate thing I will say this if
you are in the game processing signs and
if you're doing what happened with the
Jets where your video
taping them and learning their signs you
went through a lot of work and I've
always thought that was kind of
gamesmanship no way but I will say this
I had heard rumors that like they snuck
into walkthroughs if you're breaking and
entering or you're in a place that's
supposed to be off-limits now I have an
issue but you think there is an issue of
recording signs well I think it's an
issue the same way is I don't know I
change signs every week because it's too
complicated but now here's the thing but
if it's the same thing if you
accidentally on your sideline can hear
the quarterback the quarterback coach or
offensive coordinator Colin in the plate
to the quarterback I would never say
anything I would listen of course of
course you would so now you have a
better idea if you knew the verbage and
all the other stuff of what's going on
that's the same thing to steal the signs
now I could put my defense in a better
position to stop the offshore that's the
unfair part oh I know that's why he's
lying stepping are there certain things
that as a that you as a former player
that you see as gamesmanship that the
rest of the world sees as cheating other
things that you're like yeah that's
perfectly fine even though like the
average fan like the average Joe like me
would be like that's cheating I can't
believe they're getting away with that
um Jimmy TVs when I watch the game I'm
not saying there's a bunch of people
cheating I don't see that I remember
where guys used to spray the like a
little stick them on their arms which is
obviously illegal but that's not really
cheesy loves do that for you yeah but
you if you're carrying a football you
guys stick them on your forearms do the
ball sixty or four I'm a little bit more
sticking as the pine tar yeah it's not
necessarily teeny but it's not it's not
I feel like you can use a little bit but
just like pine tar if it's all over your
hat or it's all over your arm they're
like can you just be more sneaky about
this maybe better yeah it's like I heard
the starters talking about like taking
off in the NBA and it's like hey hey
Clippers you don't need to right load
management slash knee it's just up a
ninja's right knee yeah and then learn
how to lie better don't don't flaunt it
in our face as a threat word flaunt
flower flower flaunt yeah round
flan but lon I would like you to read
this in a Antonio Banderas Antonio been
there yeah that was nice walking over to
a possible dance partner alright alright
do you want to see me do least I say
salsa
that's the question I wish that was the
question I want to see the song I do I
want you to do I just saw a video my
buddy doing that dad's in a bachata yes
I don't know nothing no it was Jason a
barber's it's like Zorich okay there's a
white safety for the Eagles in the Tim
how variety I know my exhorted where did
that come from
he was my original favorite safety than
Dawkins came in I just like because he
had long hair come out to 93 Phillies
with pete incavilgia yeah
darren daulton good job give it a good
word seriously keep his dream alive man
alright if you could learned one skill a
matrix no no that's like that's like
chalupa dog Taco Bell get back to
Antonio Banderas inside a thank you
alright thank you I like it that I
listened bend Antonio yes in Tony York
stay with that okay okay you listen yes
you listen very intently to me oh here
we go if we can learn one skill of
matrix style where it's downloaded into
your brain what would you pick this is
why I don't like doing these dumbass
questions because if you could do one
skill matrix Cal style you can download
it's your brain what would it be
alright so in matrix you know Keanu
comes up in the famous line he looks at
the guy Morpheus and he goes I know
kung-fu and so he was able to learn all
of kungfu in line like that a minute so
if you can learn one trait I'm gonna
guess in bers is either gonna be
learning a language or becoming like the
greatest chef of all time
Oh chef would have been a good one I
didn't think of that yeah I feel like
you could be like a little
well I'd be like I can make every dish
in the world and like your wife comes
home when there's like 50 dishes of Paia
that's a great one
but then if you become the greatest chef
you just have to be the greatest chef as
well like for example like I don't want
to become the greatest kung fu artist in
the world because then I have to like
use that skill because now I have it and
I'm like now I have to be a professional
fighter and deal with injuries and work
out all the time and [ __ ] no thanks
so I chose piano I want to be the
greatest piano player in the world
without seeing incredible that was mine
to just know every single I will say
there's nothing more unfair than being
at some form of party right and someone
sits down and goes I'm gonna tickle the
keys a little bit and just just rest it
and then your woman looks at you and you
go
I am nothing yes and like you could use
that to become a songwriter you could be
you do ya know over guitar I'm going to
tell you do plug it's I'm a decent
guitar player I'm like a semi-decent
piano player but like when people are
good at piano it's a different category
than when you're fine it Westbrook's a
big piccolo what don't you do like you
do a lot of crazy stuff I don't know
endless you know what our 33% didn't see
you doing the periodic table that's why
I think westbrook's brain has changed
where Westbrook came up to me on Sunday
was like everybody's telling me [ __ ] the
periodic dude but he saw you name every
single one I'm not gonna ask you to miss
an amazing amazing clip i I you know I
my first thought was the piano but on
second thought I think the guitar just
imagine on the beach fire blazing oh
dude you could everyone sitting around
you hear the waves crashing onto the
beach and you pull out their guitar and
you're single
oh and things go differently for you
just in your lie don't have a time
machine
and a matrix thing yeah I got a little
bit of everything Annie and you can sing
oh my gosh no thing is like he went in
there and could suddenly like float and
stuff like if I downloaded how to be a
great dunker is my physical attributes
going to change which I can out jump
higher it's a great question I think is
it just a learned trait should we do an
entire episode where we just unpack the
realities of this matrix that way like
that's really the issues right with
a dress like if I have one bone to pick
with Morpheus did have to be a red pill
I guess if I had to download anything
for me I have such a poor recollection
of history hmm that if I could get like
all of history into my brain that like I
knew every event that it ever happened
how dangerous that would be you'd become
brand from exactly even yeah you'd know
too much you wouldn't be able to be a
person anymore like you'd you'd know all
of history you'd know what move would
lead to something good something bad
like you'd know too many permutations
you wouldn't be able to be a person
anyway you become a post here are any of
us people anymore
yes we are [ __ ] one more fan question
you have because there's one more really
good one okay yes
this is from our Dicky at our Dicky oh
my god what what a breaking ball that
guy had I know I hope it is him
r.a.dickey that was yeah how many Adam
left goes would it take to take down
Brian Westbury I think Westbrook liked
this tweet it would take it off a lot I
can tell you that but go ahead okay so
when we say takedown are we doing the
Lamar Jackson tackle um to the ground
or are we talking like knock Brian
Westbrook out I think it's a like let's
say good question scenario let's say
Brian is at the 10-yard line okay you're
at and you're at the end zone and he has
to get into the end zone
alright so obviously one of you he would
dance past you two of us we're getting
passed right you got a fifty three and
then in a third width of the field that
you have to cover just think about that
oh yeah my speed in vs. your speed my
elusiveness versus yours athletic
ability
superior athletic ability versus which
you have the longer you go the less
people ematic I feel like if I had my
stop-and-go ability like what would make
me feel made me feel really confident
like I I think that if
had 10 I'm feeling confident the
question is how much lower can I go and
still feel confident I think I could
feel confident at seven uh-huh mm-hmm
but now then I'm starting to go now
we're talking about angles yeah you know
and you're not good at that and also I'm
thinking about you know his ability to
break my tackles yeah and also much like
I said before how if the Bengals got on
the field with this with the [ __ ]
Buckeyes that they're gonna give them
everything if Westbrook knew like if
there was a camera there yeah Westbrook
is not gonna allow himself to be brought
down no and I'm gonna be like just like
Sunu be like this is my chance this is
my chance so I probably back it up and
I'd settle on eight eight eight okay it
seems like a low number there were times
in my career when I was healthy and good
again no time machine that we talked
about now I mean actually that's fun we
do it now and it doesn't say in 2006 now
if you just have a year old Adam versus
in his prime Brian Westbrook I may take
your beer and stand there and I'll be
good tackled right now but when I was
young
oh yeah it would take at that time I
would say it would take me 25 yeah I'm
like he would you would need to be like
there is an inordinate amount of love
cows on the field right yeah because I
feel like if you start one way with the
left co and then shimmy a little bit I
don't have a good three cup and go the
other way with the left co not like that
change the direction just would be you
mate if you start one way you're gonna
eliminate five to ten left goes right
there if you shimmy a little bit five to
ten more I like to think of left goes
just like careening into each other
let's say if you were one-on-one right
[Laughter]
like one left go brain you would run
right Adam right but if there's five
identical left goes with the same exact
brain theoretically they'll all make the
same strategic decisions and they won't
actually be able to flank him properly
mmm you need one left go that's like
what in a left call on the left to be
like hey cuz left coast think they know
what they're gonna do so that the
problem is too is he's gonna get a head
start because they're all gonna try and
tell the other left goes what to do one
who wants to be the mic yeah yeah so
he's gonna be like I'll fly to the left
no actually Westbrook's already started
Brea 3 would tickle - yeah no no we
start when I say okay anyway that's the
next episode of dish the playbook is 9
Adam will have goes by Matt was so am i
that's awesome that was [ __ ] BRR
did you enjoy having Eber here I did I
did it you know
that's feeling that I have of our
friendship is growing and I appreciate
that birthday of your 1819 night see
look at that
even more directed me already we're like
best friends man hey we're gonna
celebrate jr8 19th man yeah what are we
gonna do first birthday depends I think
that's a playoff game cheering mystery
parties set of encyclopedias 1718 that's
I think that's the divisional round of
the playoff it's almost always some sort
of NFL you know I think your birthday's
the championship weekend that might be
it's been there before remember the last
decade you've had a lot of Patriots a
Sunday it's a Sunday this year so it's
very very much memory either the
championship game yeah all right man
yeah it'll be fun let's celebrate let's
break it what's the party I love this
I'm not gonna say no tonight let's get
the music going Party Time in the USA
for dick up can we go back to what you
used to do which is you to have like a
one-take to go I had one you didn't have
to stop sorry sorry sorry yeah for
Westbrook to rock it man pouring burr
the rocket fan just remember it's not
enough to practice until you can do it
right you need to practice until you
can't get it wrong yeah on the lef koe
man that's deep and that was to [ __ ]
yeah see you guys later peace
you